yeah i had a i had a
thought i had an idea
and i'll share the idea with you so this
is you know not even
at the level of a hypothesis right or
this is just a thought
so
ray stanford who has
studied ufos in the 70s refers to
a sense of he calls it euphoria
spelt ufo ria euphoria
okay and he says that when
you are near one of these craft you have
a feeling of euphoria
and um he's recorded electromagnetic
variations in the electromagnetic field
from these things
and those variations happen around 12
hertz so
that's interesting because 12 hertz is
close to the
alpha rhythm frequencies that you get in
the visual cortex when you close your
eyes
okay wait sorry i just want to make sure
i'm understanding this so who's this
person who's saying this
ray stanford okay so ray stanford is
saying
that there's a phenomenon called
euphoria
yeah okay and he's defining this
phenomenon right now he's not referring
to something else
yeah the phenomenon is a feeling that
you get the sense of euphoria actually
um it's spelled things related to
euphoria to relate it to happiness
because i know that some people feel
abject terror
yeah oh certainly yeah but but but he
says that when the craft are just near
even if you're not aware of them you'll
get that sense of euphoria and he's
he claims to use this to go you know
he'll have that feeling and then go
outside and oh yeah there it is there's
one
um and takes photos and so he's done
that in the past and that's what he
claims
so i so i was curious about this because
he had also measured
variations in the electric field that
are around
on the order of 12 hertz which is close
to our alpha
variations where where they're reported
yeah so when you when he is taking
photos of a ufo he'll have
he has equipment that measures you know
em
em fields so he'll measure the electric
magnetic field
and you get variations oscillations
about 12 hertz
are prominent sometimes so
the so that kind of caught my attention
because and this is where the thought
comes in right this is his claim
you know i have not seen this myself
i've not measured it and so i
i can't you know testify to the
to how true it is but my thought
what struck me was that 12 hertz is
close to your alpha rhythm
and and um
and so if you have strong electric and
magnet oscillating electric and magnetic
fields near these things you're going to
induce currents into the brain and if
these currents are at 12 hertz they
couldn't train the algorithm you can
actually entrain of their
alpha rhythms so um so you could enter
and train an alpha rhythm which would
which could very well make you feel
you know calm or restful or sleepy or
you know euphoric or something like that
now of course
this could be overridden by the terror
of seeing you know
you know this craft and you know aliens
coming out of it or whatever
might happen but but it that was my that
was my thought
well maybe maybe that's where the
euphoria comes from it's comes from
these oscillations in the electric field
and then it made me think that um
and i had this thought watching the
video
from skinwalker wrench of the disc in
the sky
with the cow dying right the cow was
dying
while the disc was hovering over it um
where was this from
this was taken at skinwalker ranch and
it was in
their there's their tv series their
documentary series
right what's the host name dude travis
travis taylor travis taylor yeah
is that the series you're referring to
yeah it's the one yeah i would like to
talk to travis have you ever spoken to
him
yeah i have i've met him he's an
interesting guy yeah yeah so
so in that in that case you had you had
the you had the
the disc is hovering or some distance
above the cow the cow
actually died there and
and it was acting funny beforehand and
it made me think well
the cow's brains are different sizes and
i don't know what
frequency their alpha rhythm is at so i
thought
what if what if these craft are inducing
currents into the cow's brain and then
it
makes them panic or something instead of
giving them the sense of euphoria
ah that's fascinating and so
maybe these maybe so what if what if
they're killing the cows by accident so
here's just a thought
they're killing the cows by accident
right and then they're
trying to figure out why the cows are
dying whenever they fly near them
right so then they go down and they did
take some samples and collect some data
to figure out why the cows are dying
maybe that it's a thought that's all